et concernant le logement
j'ai déjà dit ce que je sais ce que j'en
pensais je
il faut que l'état arrête d'avoir cette
vision
centralisée il n'en a pas les moyens il
n'en a pas la compétence il n'a pas géré
cela
c'est son aux élus locaux décret le
cadre général dans la maîtrise de
l'urbanisme et de l'aménagement
il faut être à l'écouté des acteurs du
sujet mais enfin comment on peut dire
que la maison individuelle on est en
france comment on peut dire que la
maison individuelle n'est ni écologique
ni économique ni sociale c'est à dire
comment on peut insulter
l'immense majorité des français est au
fond de l'immense majorité des élus qui
pour assurer le développement de leur
village c'est dire la préservation de
leur école faire venir des familles qui
ont besoin d'un jardin pour élever leurs
enfants dont c'est le rêve comment on
peut dire ça et mettre ça dans le débat
public dont je comprends qu'il
rétropédale mais je comprends pas que ça
puisse aller dans le débat public sert
c'est la trême c c et en plus c'était un
discours donc ça veut dire que c'est
bien la technostructure qui a écrit et
sap a été relu parce qu'évidemment c'est
ça le combat culturel qui a porté c'est
celui ci c'est pour ça la dignité d'un
parlementaire c'est aussi de mettre dans
débat public ce ce besoin d' équilibre
sur les maisons individuelles
ce qu'il faut c'est être à l'écouté des
besoins et de la maîtrise des sols et
donc c'est peut-être et tu l'as dit rémy
c'est peut-être des maisons plus petit
ou à jardin plus petit on n'a plus
besoin forcément d'un jardin 900 mètres
carrés il faut une offre de cette nature
mais une offre avec un jardin et ça ça
correspond aux besoins et aux demandes
des promoteurs et trouver le bon
équilibre mais il faut continuer de se
développer il faut continuer de
progresser ou alors on dit bon on veut
plus de français
la démographie est un problème et puis
on se replie sur soi même et on va gérer
ce qu'on peut donc il faut être à
l'écouté de l'évolution des besoins mais
pas prendre bille en tête de façon
orthogonale la réalité d'une sociologie
qui correspond ciel identité de notre
pays
[Musique]